Let's say I have a line that
goes through the origin.
I'll draw it in R2, but this
can be extended to an
arbitrary Rn.
Let me draw my axes.
Those are my axes right there,
not perfectly drawn, but you
get the idea.
Let me draw a line that goes
through the origin here.
So that is my line there.
And we know that a line in any
Rn-- we're doing it in R2--
can be defined as just all of
the possible scalar multiples
of some vector.
So let's say that this is
some vector right here
that's on the line.
We can define our line.
We could say l is equal to
the set of all the scalar
multiples-- let's say that
that is v, right there.
So it's all the possible scalar
multiples of our vector
v where the scalar multiples,
by definition, are just any
real number.
So obviously, if you take all
of the possible multiples of
v, both positive multiples and
negative multiples, and less
than 1 multiples, fraction
multiples, you'll have a set
of vectors that will essentially
define or specify
every point on that line that
goes through the origin.
And we know, of course, if this
wasn't a line that went
through the origin,
you would have to
shift it by some vector.
It would have to be some
other vector plus cv.
But anyway, we're starting off
with this line definition that
goes through the origin.
What I want to do in this video
is to define the idea of
a projection onto l of
some other vector x.
So let me draw my
other vector x.
Let's say that this right here
is my other vector x.
Now, a projection, I'm going
to give you just a sense of
it, and then we'll define it a
little bit more precisely.
A projection, I always imagine,
is if you had some
light source that were
perpendicular somehow or
orthogonal to our line-- so
let's say our light source was
shining down like this, and
I'm doing that direction
because that is perpendicular
to my line, I imagine the
projection of x onto this line
as kind of the shadow of x.
So if this light was coming
down, I would just draw a
perpendicular like that, and the
shadow of x onto l would
be that vector right there.
So we can view it as the shadow
of x on our line l.
That's one way to think of it.
Another way to think of it,
and you can think of it
however you like, is how much of
x goes in the l direction?
So the technique would
be the same.
You would draw a perpendicular
from x to l, and you say, OK
then how much of l would have to
go in that direction to get
to my perpendicular?
Either of those are how I
think of the idea of a
projection.
I think the shadow is part of
the motivation for why it's
even called a projection,
right?
When you project something,
you're beaming light and
seeing where the light
hits on a wall, and
you're doing that here.
You're beaming light and you're
seeing where that light
hits on a line in this case.
But you can't do anything
with this definition.
This is just kind of an
intuitive sense of what a
projection is.
So we need to figure out some
way to calculate this, or a
more mathematically precise
definition.
And one thing we can do is,
when I created this
projection-- let me actually
draw another projection of
another line or another vector
just so you get the idea.
If I had some other vector over
here that looked like
that, the projection of this
onto the line would look
something like this.
You would just draw a
perpendicular and its
projection would be like that.
But I don't want to talk
about just this case.
I want to give you the sense
that it's the shadow of any
vector onto this line.
So how can we think about it
with our original example?
In every case, no matter how
I perceive it, I dropped a
perpendicular down here.
And so if we construct a vector
right here, we could
say, hey, that vector is
always going to be
perpendicular to the line.
And we can do that.
I wouldn't have been talking
about it if we couldn't.
So let me define this vector,
which I've not
even defined it.
What is this vector
going to be?
If this vector-- let me
not use all these.
We know we want to somehow
get to this blue vector.
Let me keep it in blue.
That blue vector is the
projection of x onto l.
That's what we want to get to.
Now, one thing we can
look at is this pink
vector right there.
What is that pink vector?
That pink vector that I just
drew, that's the vector x
minus the projection, minus this
blue vector over here,
minus the projection
of x onto l, right?
If you add the projection to
the pink vector, you get x.
So if you add this blue
projection of x to x minus the
projection of x, you're, of
course, you going to get x.
We also know that this pink
vector is orthogonal to the
line itself, which means it's
orthogonal to every vector on
the line, which also means that
its dot product is going
to be zero.
So let me define the projection
this way.
The projection, this is going
to be my slightly more
mathematical definition.
The projection onto l of some
vector x is going to be some
vector that's in l, right?
I drew it right here,
this blue vector.
I'll trace it with
white right here.
Some vector in l where, and
this might be a little bit
unintuitive, where x minus the
projection vector onto l of x
is orthogonal to my line.
So I'm saying the projection--
this is my definition.
I'm defining the projection of x
onto l with some vector in l
where x minus that projection
is orthogonal to l.
This is my definition.
That is a little bit more
precise and I think it makes a
bit of sense why it connects to
the idea of the shadow or
projection.
But how can we deal with this?
I mean, this is still
just in words.
How can I actually calculate
the projection of x onto l?
Well, the key clue here is this
notion that x minus the
projection of x is
orthogonal to l.
So let's see if we can
use that somehow.
So the first thing we need to
realize is, by definition,
because the projection of x onto
l is some vector in l,
that means it's some scalar
multiple of v, some scalar
multiple of our defining vector,
of our v right there.
So we could also say, look, we
could rewrite our projection
of x onto l.
We could write it as some scalar
multiple times our
vector v, right?
We can say that.
This is equivalent to
our projection.
Now, we also know that x minus
our projection is orthogonal
to l, so we also know that x
minus our projection-- and I
just said that I could rewrite
my projection as some multiple
of this vector right there.
You could see it the
way I drew it here.
It almost looks like it's
2 times its vector.
So we know that x minus our
projection, this is our
projection right here,
is orthogonal to l.
Orthogonality, by definition,
means its dot product with any
vector in l is 0.
So let's dot it with
some vector in l.
Or we could dot it with
this vector v.
That's what we use
to define l.
So let's dot it with v,
and we know that that
must be equal to 0.
We're taking this vector right
here, dotting it with v, and
we know that this has
to be equal to 0.
That has to be equal to 0.
So let's use our properties of
dot products to see if we can
calculate a particular value of
c, because once we know a
particular value of c, then we
can just always multiply that
times the vector v, which we
are given, and we will have
our projection.
And then I'll show it to you
with some actual numbers.
So let's see if we can
calculate a c.
So if we distribute this c--
oh, sorry, if we distribute
the v, we know the dot
product exhibits the
distributive property.
This expression can be rewritten
as x dot v, right? x
dot v minus c times v dot v.
I rearranged things.
We know that c minus cv dot
v is the same thing.
We could write it as minus cv.
This is minus c times v dot v,
and all of this, of course, is
equal to 0.
And if we want to solve for c,
let's add cv dot v to both
sides of the equation.
And you get x dot v is equal
to c times v dot v.
Solving for c, let's divide
both sides of this
equation by v dot v.
You get-- I'll do it in
a different color.
c is equal to this: x dot
v divided by v dot v.
Now, what was c?
We are saying the projection of
x-- let me write it here.
The projection of x onto
l is equal to some
scalar multiple, right?
We know it's in the line, so
it's some scalar multiple of
this defining vector,
the vector v.
And we just figured out
what that scalar
multiple is going to be.
It's going to be x dot v over v
dot v, and this, of course,
is just going to be
a number, right?
This is a scalar still.
Even though we have all these
vectors here, when you take
their dot products, you just end
up with a number, and you
multiply that number times v.
You just kind of scale v and
you get your projection.
So in this case, the way I
drew it up here, my dot
product should end up with some
scaling factor that's
close to 2, so that if I start
with a v and I scale it up by
2, this value would be 2, and
I'd get a projection that
looks something like that.
Now, this looks a little
abstract to you, so let's do
it with some real vectors, and
I think it'll make a little
bit more sense.
And nothing I did here
only applies to R2.
Everything I did here can be
extended to an arbitrarily
high dimension, so even though
we're doing it in R2, and R2
and R3 is where we tend to
deal with projections the
most, this could apply to Rn.
Let me do this particular
case.
Let me define my line l to
be the set of all scalar
multiples of the vector-- I
don't know, let's say the
vector 2, 1, such that
c is any real number.
Let me draw my axes here.
That's my vertical axis.
This is my horizontal
axis right there.
And so my line is all the
scalar multiples of the
vector 2 dot 1.
And actually, let me just call
my vector 2 dot 1, let me call
that right there the vector v.
Let me draw that.
So I go 1, 2, go up 1.
That right there
is my vector v.
And the line is all of
the possible scalar
multiples of that.
So let me draw that.
So all the possible scalar
multiples of that and you just
keep going in that direction, or
you keep going backwards in
that direction or anything
in between.
That's what my line is, all
of the scalar multiples
of my vector v.
Now, let's say I have another
vector x, and let's say that x
is equal to 2, 3.
Let me draw x. x is 2, and
then you go, 1, 2, 3.
So x will look like this.
Vector x will look like that.
Well, let me draw it a little
bit better than that.
Vector x will look like that.
That is vector x.
But what we want to do
is figure out the
projection of x onto l.
We can use this definition
right here.
So let me write it down.
The projection of x onto
l is equal to what?
It's equal to x dot v, right?
Where v is the defining
vector for our line.
So it's equal to x, which is
2, 3, dot v, which is 2, 1,
all of that over v dot v.
So all of that over 2, 1, dot
2, 1 times our original
defining vector v.
So what's our original
defining vector?
It's this one right
here, 2, 1.
So times the vector, 2, 1.
And what does this equal?
When you take these two dot of
each other, you have 2 times 2
plus 3 times 1, so 4 plus
3, so you get 7.
This all simplified to 7.
And then this, you get 2
times 2 plus 1 times 1,
so 4 plus 1 is 5.
So you get 7/5.
That will all simplified to 5.
That was a very fast
simplification.
You might have been daunted
by this strange-looking
expression, but when you take
dot products, they actually
tend to simplify very quickly.
And then you just multiply
that times your defining
vector for the line.
So we're scaling it up
by a factor of 7/5.
So multiply it times
the vector 2, 1,
and what do you get?
You get the vector-- let me
do it in a new color.
You get the vector, 14/5
and the vector 7/5.
And just so we can visualize
this or plot it a little
better, let me write
it as decimals.
14/5 is 2 and 4/5,
which is 2.8.
And this is 1 and 2/5,
which is 1.4.
And so the projection of x
onto l is 2.8 and 1.4.
So 2.8 is right about there,
and I go 1.4 is right about
there, so the vector is going
to be right about there.
I haven't even drawn
this too precisely,
but you get the idea.
This is the projection.
Our computation shows
us that this is the
projection of x onto l.
If we draw a perpendicular right
there, we see that it's
consistent with our idea of
this being the shadow of x
onto our line now.
Well, now we actually can
calculate projections.
In the next video, I'll actually
show you how to
figure out a matrix
representation for this, which
is essentially a
transformation.